my favorite story of this year and this
is one that I love so much it's by a
beautiful woman Joe called Isa Bryson oh
this is a great story this I I I
remember last time I was at your Club
the mothership we touched on it briefly
when we when you and I were talking but
this to me is the most beautiful story
of a beautiful woman living her best
life Jamie we're going to need to see a
photo of this beautiful woman Joe you're
you're know you're happily married I
don't remember you bringing this up
right well this happened in Scotland
so what is the story okay so there's a
two-time male rapist called Adam Graham
convicted male rapist right and then B
before he was going to s be sent to
prison he got uh what constant and I
like to called uh rapid onset prison
dysphoria prison prison onset you put it
to the line but it's prison onset gender
this for it this is the guy so now he's
a woman in woman's prison yeah put him
in a woman's prison there's a clitoris
Joe if you if you're wondering they're
doing that in America too yeah there's
uh quite a few there's one person that
identifies as a woman went to jail and
got two people pregnant in jail
like like what it just seems so silly
and I'm as liberal as you can get but
I'm not on board with that well I'm as
liberal as you can get too that's what's
so crazy it's like they they push it so
far to cuckoo land that any rejection of
any of these outrageously stupid ideas
becomes far right yeah yeah far right if
you don't think a guy with a regular
dick who who's been straight his whole
life should be able to identify as a
woman and go into a women's prison and
be with women like come on and this
guy's a rapist he's a threat we know
he's a threat it's so crazy it's just so
crazy that they'll take it all the way
to prison and then you've got
politicians who on question time which
is our most prestigious political debate
show they had a member of the S SMP
because this in Scotland so this is a
member of the Scottish national party
and this SNP member was
asked is Adam or is ISA Graham male or
female and you know what she responded
this woman she went they're a
rapist refus to even acknowledge that
it's a male that it's a man what a weird
world so weird isn't it I would have
never imagined if you came to me in 2013
you said guess what's going to be a
crazy subject 10 years from
now guys who just say they're women and
they put them in women's presence what
come on that can't be a thing imagine if
you like you had to dress up like a
woman for a whole year in order for it
to be like legit like there was a rule
like you could do it but you had to
dress up like a whole year so criminals
just started dressing up like women and
that became like the thing you know like
guys like the SAG like that's how they
wear their pants in prison right so they
like to Sag it's like part of the part
of the thing what if that becomes the
thing like you know there's only one way
to get locked up with women you got to
dress like a woman all the time so you
got to dress like a woman for like a
whole year in order to be accepted it
would be the new style of like just just
people would just like I'm a criminal I
don't give a [__] this is what I do if I
get arrested at least I'm going to get
arrested with women yeah I mean guys
would start wearing dresses and I'll be
honest with you man I don't want to be
talking about trans my [__] my whole
life I don't you have to you have no
choice I you will comply I no no I you
will comply or we will freeze your bank
account
stop I don't want to be talking about
this [__] but when this is happening
what are we supposed to do we're just
supposed to sit there and pretend it's
not happening well if you have any
opinion other than what you're supposed
to have then you're some kind of a
terrible person and a trans phobe and
that's nuts because there's always room
for crazy you got to leave room for
crazy you got to leave room for crazy in
all groups of people including trans
people and if you don't if you're trying
to pretend that that you know you have
this this group that anybody can join
and these are new rules and we're all
living in Narnia now come on come on
there's always going to be crazy people
of course the emperor is [__] naked
man an Emperor's naked as [__] and he's
got a heart on he's right there yeah and
he's like I want access to the female
changing
rooms and we're like come this way Madam
and you're a bigot if you don't agree
imagine Fran Ghana was like you know
what I'm a woman I wonder what
percentage of like people with kids
believe that versus people who don't
have kids that's an interesting right
cuz I wonder if so many like there's so
many people that have ideas people that
don't have children they have ideas that
I think you they just have this uh
ideology that they subscribe to but with
no consequences for anyone that's really
young that they love and care about and
then when then they have kids and then
there's someone young that they love and
care about you start looking at the
world as a much more dangerous place you
start saying oh these people like little
kids like there was some little girl who
got kidnapped really recently they they
found
they use Geo tracking of cell phones and
[__] and the person's fingerprints from
The Ransom note and they got her back
pretty quickly luckily but you know
9-year-old girl just gets kidnapped like
there's there's people like that in the
world and when you have children you
think like that like someone could steal
your kids like that's real someone could
hurt your kids and someone you know
could go in the locker room and watch
your kid go to the bathroom because they
decide that they're a girl and that
doesn't mean that there's not people
that are legitimate trans and identify
as women and that's who they are and
they're not perverts and they're not
creeps of course of course that exists
too but you're opening the door if
someone just says I'm trans I can use
that restroom you're opening the door
for perverts you 100% most certainly are
this doesn't deny the existence of trans
people but we have to be honest about
what could possibly happen that's why if
people are uncomfortable with biological
males walking around female locker rooms
is because some people are liars and
they're con artists and they're not
really it's this person that's like been
trapped in a man's body their whole life
they're [__] perverts and they want
to be around kids or they want to be
around women they want to make them
uncomfortable they want people to stare
at their dick while they walk around and
know that they can't say anything about
it that's real too sure that's real too
this doesn't discount the the problem
that trans people have with integrating
into society and being accepted that's
real too that's real too but you have to
understand that if you just have this
blanket policy where no one can question
anything about this stuff you're you're
opening the door to abuse right yeah and
you have a front door in your house not
because you think everyone is going to
come and steal [__] from your house but
you know that some people will so you
have to put certain things in place to
protect yourself and your family it's
it's the most obvious thing man well
it's just there's no screening in in
women's bathrooms like you don't know
whether someone's a creep you have no
idea no it's not like you know getting
into a [__] a job where they have to
do a background check on you you know
it's it's not like applying for some top
secet position where they have to make
sure that you know you're someone who
could be trusted with information no
it's like a bathroom so it could be like
someone justs out of jail puts on a
dress goes into a women's room that mean
that's what we're accepting today that
that is a possibility and women that
feel vulnerable in those situations are
[__] terrified and rightfully so
because if they do encounter something
like that they get no support no one no
one will say anything no no one will
take your side you saw what happened
with that the thing that happened in
Hollywood at that massage parlor oh yeah
yeah in in California Bonkers man
someone who had a history of being a sex
offender walking around naked in the
women's room they complained and then
all a sudden there's protest there it's
like come on kids